[Music]
hello there another month approaches and
another bunch of games want your time
this is the series we look at the best
games for every budget and the Run of
finding a new free-to-play game
continues if your wallet needs time to
heal I'm Adam if this video helps you at
all please think about leaving a like
thank you much Lee let's do this
I planned on telling you all about the
latest DC game kill the Justice League
after a huge gameplay reveal in a
PlayStation state of play well after the
audience was far from impressed the
decision was made to postpone that game
until 2024 so we won't be hunting down
the evil versions of Superman Batman and
Co until February next year so any Lord
of the Rings fans in the house a game
definitely sticking to its release date
after two years of delays is none other
than Gollum set before the Lord of the
Rings books we play as Gollum hell-bent
on finding his precious ring the
gameplay Loop is focused around stealth
as we climb walls and fit into cracks
and crevices to stay hidden from threats
misdirecting enemies and using
distraction to progress Gollum is
renowned by having two voices in his
head a constant struggle between good
and bad light and dark right and wrong
which is said to play a part in the
story here your choices in-game will add
up and eventually one of his
personalities will take over the other
and dominate future interactions I
wonder if this is the first game where
the protagonist that looks like a real
gamer March 25th is release date on
Playstation Xbox PC and the switch
version is in the works too
[Music]
next eraser in the world of Lego this is
Lego 2K Drive set in the open world of
bricklandia we are primarily pushed to
take part in races where everything made
of those bricks is explodable our
ultimate task is to obtain the sky
trophy by taking on the game's evil
villain but Lego 2K is not solely eraser
there's tons of non-racing challenges to
find in this open world like launching
from a ramp and trying to hit targets
dotted around surviving horror showdowns
with skeletons and I saw an egg hunting
minigame to push giant eggs into frying
pans this game has plenty of weird to go
with the racing retailing at 60.60 Euros
or 50 pounds here in the UK I honestly
think this Lego game will struggle to
find its audience at that price but I'd
love to be proven wrong Lego 2K Drive
hits Playstation Xbox PC and twitch on
May 19th
a game I'm personally excited about is
Humanity if you've ever played something
like Pikmin or Lemmings you already have
an understanding of how Humanity plays
we wake up as a dog and watch humans
aimlessly following one another around
it's our job to lead them into the light
those humans follow command we give them
so I guess we literally back out orders
rammed with obstacles and puzzling
multi-level stages we must help them all
survive in ever increasingly difficult
scenarios and that's when the game
throws another curveball at you we are
not the only group here there are
another bunch of people called the
others a war will occur if these two
sets of Walkers get too close to one
another which means weapons will
actually become available and some
freaky Star Wars encroaching lightsaber
battles between the blue of humanity and
the red of the others ensue also
confirmed is a stage Creator allowing
all players around the world to build a
mission and make it available to
everyone else and that's not the end
humanity is also on psvr and psvr too so
there's a lot of potential here Humanity
releases on PlayStation and PC and you
you may already own it as it's coming to
PS plus from day one on the extra tier
on May 16th definitely one worth
watching out for
let's do this month's free games have a
look-see at Omega Strikers this is a
MOBA by the way how do I explain this
one imagine if air hockey was big enough
to run around on and we all had weapons
to fight each other a mega Strikers
calls itself football a lightning fast
three on three totally free to play
action sports game the premise is simple
score more goals than your opponent to
help with that are a cast of characters
with unique skill sets ranging from
subtle Buffs to allies debuffs to
opponents and more impressively the
weapons and items each character brings
to the field of play each player has a
stagger bar which as characters take
damage fills up making it easier to
knock them down then on top of that are
experience points from scoring goals
making passes knocking down the enemy
and making saves those points are then
put into power-ups for your Strikers it
takes about a minute to learn this game
but about a thousand hours to perfect it
whether you're here to score goals or
you just like beating people up on Mega
Strikers has you covered so will you try
it a mega Strikers releases on April
27th on Playstation Xbox PC switch and
mobile too another free-to-play game
that I said was coming to console last
month is warlander it was due out this
very week yet at the last minute a tweet
went out from Toy logic that sadly says
the console version has been delayed it
will still be a free-to-play game when
it arrives but we don't have an exact
date for now so I'll keep you updated
the only other free-to-play game newly
available right now is for psvr 2 in the
shape of cactus Cowboy plants at War and
um maybe it plays better than it looks I
haven't had a chance to try it but I
thought I'd pass this on just in case
you have psbr 2 but not many things to
play on it
[Music]
Journey was an amazing experience that
many of us have been trying to find
another game like for years which is why
after us has my attention an action
platformer in which we play as Gaia the
spirit of life on Earth who embarks on a
journey to see what happened to the
world she loves Gaia leaves behind this
Lush Greenery and can sing to call out
to other life forms that have survived
whatever cataclysm event has happened
here but Gaia won't go through this
without any opposition fighting
mechanics can be seen in the trailers
and numerous puzzles must be overcome
too after us Launches on May 23rd on
Playstation PC and Xbox series a game I
wanted to put on your radar is wrestle
Quest okay hear me out a WWE style
wrestlefest but it's actually a fantasy
RPG in fact a turn-based RPG in fact
packed with 80s and 90s real-life
wrestlers like Macho Man Randy Savage
the Legion of Doom and I'm sure I saw
Jake the Snake Roberts too we must go
from amateur minnow and slowly build a
power Persona improve our trash talking
promos perfect the best moveset and
build hype to hopefully one day claim
the heavyweight championship retailing
at around 30 this could be a great game
for fans of both wrestling and jrpgs
okay I'm the only one hyped I get it
[Music]
a few other video games releasing in may
include the last gen versions of
Hogwarts Legacy on May 5th for spoken
gets DRC in the shape of Tanto we trust
on May 26th hello neighbor VR search and
rescue drops on psvr 2 on May 25th and
Age of Wonders 4 hit shelves on May 2nd
but without a doubt the biggest game of
the month is the Legend of Zelda tears
of the Kingdom on the Nintendo switch I
know this is a Playstation focused
Channel but not to mention this latest
Zelda game would be a crime the
follow-up to 2018's game of the year
will no doubt be the reason other AAA
games have run away from the month of
May completely maybe that's what
happened to kill the Justice League hmm
so what are you playing this month as
I'm saying this Star Wars Jedi Survivor
releases this week too what a time to be
a gamer I'm definitely gonna try a mega
Strikers it could be something good to
play with friends and I can't resist
wrestle Quest what are you playing this
month I'm Adam you're awesome thanks for
sticking around till the end here have a
random dad joke a guy walks into a bar
Andy gets disqualified from the limbo
contest see ya
[Music]
foreign